hi there I'm Seth Juarez and I'm
chatting with Microsoft researchers
research is Katja Hoffman and Evelyn
Villegas about project Malmo and AI
testing environment based upon my
current minecraft welcome hi how's
everybody doing today
fantastic I heard about this topic
recently and it absolutely was really
impressive and here's why like I was
talking before I talk to Joshua Ben geo
about deep learning and one of the
things he said is that one of the
state-of-the-art things that he wants to
do is he wants to use deep learning for
exploratory AI so why don't you talk
about project Malmo and why this is a
perfect piece of software that I was
telling you absolutely I'm really seeing
minecraft as one of those stepping
stones that are going to allow us to
push the state-of-the-art
Nai and eventually work towards more
complex real-world application two of
the things that I'm really excited about
that we can do in Malmo which is based
on minecraft is that first we can invest
in this kind of lifelong learning so
coming up with approaches that would
strip from smaller kind of simpler tasks
that learn common-sense knowledge and
then gives it up to eventually those
harder and harder task the other part
that really exciting word is this
concept of collaborative AI so what
happens when you put more than one agent
into an environment for example how can
our agents learn to collaborate and what
happens when you put a human in there
can they learn to figure out what the
human is trying to achieve and how they
can help them keep their own project
Malmo tell us about it from your
perspective sure
so this is a very exciting for dinner I
actually want to rain right now the
collaborative aspects that schedule
talking about in fact when we started
the project when cutta cutta with the
researchers like working on this project
we started interacting with the external
community up front just to understand
first what was unique what were the
requirements and we did a few what we
called some technology
they just configure a solution for the
community and the pretty student figure
rather actually to be fantastic if it
would work more closely the community
which ended up bringing Manuel little
platform to the open source and since
then actually we had thousands of people
you've been using that's amazing so you
started up front by thinking we're just
going to put this out what did people
been doing is you mentioned thousand
what are people been doing this
technology absolutely so we were
planning this as a tool for the research
community from this start and really
thinking about how such a platform could
advance the state of the art in AI one
thing we hadn't really anticipated was
the level of enthusiasm we get from
outside the research community we get
high school students to learn to program
on the mono platform and that's really
exciting for them because you can
actually see what an algorithm does when
you new to Chester and agent we get a
lot of interest from university
professors who use it in their in their
courses to teach students about concepts
in AI and programming and reinforcement
learning so there's a huge diversity of
uses a lot of times you only see the
visitor numbers on github we see that
there's a lot of people but there's a
lot bubbling hunters under the surface
that we're not even aware so if you have
some cool users for my mode that you
would like to tell us about definitely
get in touch we were really really eager
to hear about other what's the most
surprising thing you've seen people view
project Mellon because I say your first
cuy the most surprising person I'd say
like yeah so there was a sixth grader
younger yet who actually came to my
office and was completely inspired she
was doing a visit as part of some
students gathering at Microsoft and and
just heard about man
he really heard about minecraft run drop
and so but then he heard about mono and
was like wow so he started interrupts
actually we do research and say you know
wow now I can actually have some a my
agents I can play with us I can learn
about it so that first term it is
probably the most surprising person I
trying to use manual also showing that
the viral entry can be as low or as high
as you want it to be and that's amazing
were they were they actually coating
these things to go around and like mine
self and build stuff or what were what
was this sixth grader actually doing
interest or what were they doing I think
they were trying to do a bit of both
like the first thing they were really
trying to learn about diversity for
agents how can I can I start cooking but
actually the person started coding
actually so yes it was we're not an
environment like to experiment for fun
with characters he was very familiar
with so let's talk about a testbed like
project Malmo why is it an important
thing well in real world applications
which in the long run we're going to
enable new rehabilitation we're not
doing this for the sake of learning to
play minecraft if we if that's what we
need we have people who are pretty good
at it but what we really want to is to
isolate certain aspects of qatal huge
program of AI and start to make progress
in those specific dimensions and in a
simulated environment like this we tend
specific specifically construct the
tasks that allow us to really push on
those dimensions the for example if
someone wants to do research on Mikey
modal approaches that integrate language
and visual aspects of an environment
this is something you can set up very
easily in mammal and it allows you to
really focus on the learning approaches
this instead of having to do all this
data collection I'm setting up and a
task in the real world which can be much
slower and eventually we see this
research you know to feed into this the
river of applications but first we can
push really understand what's going on
why do you think it's such an important
well I think it's very important because
I'm going to go back to the community so
actually I want to talk about so
collaborative AI challenge that we've
done recently and this is one way I
scuttled mentioned in earlier reading
the goal of the background not just
Windows platform for the sake of doing
it is really to help advance the state
of the art to get people engaged also to
use it for people maybe to just learn
like 3d students but also some
enthusiasts actually are interested in
learning about all these approaches so
the team put together a challenge and a
challenge so I think capture will be
determinative later later on in more
detail but I want to emphasize the
interesting part about that challenge is
that it's really collaborative and it's
all really about collaborative AI and I
think that's something we're trying to
do which is different from what is out
there and project manual actually is
ideal for that which is bringing people
together to try to do some specific
stuff like was creating something on the
context of the challenge that we had the
production is fast results are trying to
catch a pig together I feel like we've
talked about it so luckily you show us a
little demo and how it's how this works
what do you got absolutely I think you
can actually see this on this kind of
area what I have here is the task that
we set out as the collaborative AI
challenge we are going to be a human
agent interacting with another agent and
the task of the students was to actually
create an agent that would take the road
that we're at that we're playing here
okay so you can see here we're getting
ready to catch the pig they're two
agents in the small enclosure here we
are controlling the red agent here and
there's another one here in the corner
to catch the pig we actually have to
corner it so we have to collaborate like
that will only work if the other agent
is actually able to collaborate with us
sure so let's see if they're good
collaborator so you're the red one and
the blue one is the actual AI one
exactly so you can see how I'm
controlling this one over here and you
can already see that the other agent is
moving towards the pig so that's a
pretty good indication
that they're actually trying to
collaborate with us in this inference
this kind of understanding what the
other agents intentions are and how our
plan our behavior can fit in to ordinate
wisdom that is really the core of this
challenge if the other agent were to
move around randomly or we're trying to
trick us then that would have a
difference we should draw a different
conclusion we shouldn't try to
collaborate with them so this is
interesting now is this because I'm
looking at this and I can think of is
I'm kind of a programmer too it's just
like our people writing deterministic
algorithms for them and even
probabilistic are they going full AI
machine learning because what are they
doing for fantastic questions so we
actually had 83 teams from around the
world participating in this first
version of the challenge and what we saw
in the winning teams was that there was
a huge variety in terms of the
approaches that to Detroit some people
really went down the deep reinforcement
learning route and had some great
insights into how to learn efficiently
in the kind of more complex modeling
environment others went to class today I
wrote some spend a lot of time really
manually modeling this environment
someone's the belief modeling and
probabilistic inference and at the
moment what we saw was that a lot of
those approaches are kind of on par with
each other so what I'm looking forward
to is seeing how are those different
communities people with those different
backgrounds can learn from each other
maybe integrate different ideas and use
that to come up with more new innovative
approaches to solving those kinds of
collaborative tasks what surprised you
about this challenge because I'm sure
you put this out there and you're like I
wonder what's going to happen and then
you got a lot of response what was your
reaction to this well it's all fantastic
to see so many people collaborate you
know ask a chiral dimension in so the
task itself seemed kind of simple but
actually what was really interesting
when we have the winners come and talk
about the different approaches first of
all actually some of them just
collaborated when they're just to
present the approach that speaks to the
point of you know the person some of
them are not that different
and the other aspect also very
interesting I thought was actually even
for us like trying to learn how people
are collaborating and some of them had
some a sorceress find candles to trick
the peace of the speaker I think also
for learning a lot about how agents
whether human or a our agents are also
trying to collaborate to to have to
achieve a specific Department for the
program so that was religion in deal the
challenge I think if they're also seen
what motivates people what are the
incentive to learning a lot about that
too as we develop challenging so as I'm
looking at this if I was in a core part
of this challenge I would have to
program the agent to help me corner the
page effectively so as I how do i I'm a
programmer how do I write this because I
if I remember right it's written Java or
at least the at least a minecraft is but
is there can you use any kind of
language how do I get started what do I
do to make this work fantastic question
so we from the start to find project
mama to be as open as possible so we
didn't want to exclude any audiences so
we put a lot of effort into making this
platform actually cross-platform so it
runs on Linux Windows Mac OS and people
can use their favorite programming
language to start and code agents so
we're purging memo except essentially
provides an API that hooks into the
minecraft games of uses the morning
framework to get information about the
state of the world and to send commands
to the to minecraft but our platform
takes away all the complexity of
actually interacting with the Minecraft
game so that researchers can just focus
on 32 right code of what the agent
should observe how it should interpret
those interface observations and how it
should consequently try to act in the
world the languages we support include
DZ plus plus Java Python Lewis you know
there's a lot for for everyone I also
saw there's a c-sharp on that's my
favorite one so what I'm writing when
I'm writing
when I'm running this stuff am i I'm
trying to understand what this looks
like because it feels like there's some
kind of wrapper and that I'm sending
information to and then it I'm querying
for information is that the whole event
what do you think yes absolutely
pizza yes we can think about this F this
interactive who between the agent on one
site and the world the Minecraft
environment on the other so for the
person writing the agent that looks
quite simply s you're pulling state from
the environment and then you send an
action back you can really start to
think about this kind of interactive
loop that is often used for something
reinforcement learning but that also
matches a lot of different interactive
scenarios where agents have to generally
learn to interact with the rope one of
the things I notice is that this
challenge was very constrained is there
is there a way that I can code up let's
just say for example there's some
heuristics about how I think I could
stay alive a night in my pack and I have
kids so that's why I know a lot about
Minecraft my idea so let's just say
there's certain assumptions I have about
staying alive in Minecraft is there a
way to code it into that so that it
could be an incan unconstraint to see
how it actually do something yes so the
mammal platform is really open-ended in
the sense that it supports infinitely
many different tasks I'm just showing
here a small snippet from the XML that
it's actually used to define the
collaborative tasks that that we saw
earlier earlier and you can define kind
of the world that the agent enters you
can start from any safe minecraft game
you can add additional elements you can
draw entities into this world we can
really set it up in whatever way you
like and then you can provide
information about what kinds of agents
should be put in that environment so you
can give them a certain reward function
you can give them observations or
command handlers and then this way
there's no limit to what kinds of tasks
you can implement there so if you think
you can come up with an agent that will
survive the first 20 day absolutely
that's it has to control absolutely
they can communicate with each other
exactly so why communicate with each
other it's like you can send it because
I know you can chat I'm on top and they
can get receive that tax and do stuff
exactly exactly you can start to have
collaborative tasks where agent has to
learn to talk to each other when when
necessary and I feel like I just want to
start coding something right now is it
so this XML file describes this starting
point you mentioned that it has like if
you could scroll down to where it
actually describes the agent because
it's like our audience can see the agent
can so there's an agent and so that
agent how is it how does it you know
that's what it has what it starts with
how do you tell it like because I
imagine like is that like I used to
write games a long time ago and there
was his loop that I would be able to
know here's the thing here's what
everything is around it do this how do I
tell the start file to look at this
function and then what do I get out of
that function maybe I'm asking right
right for that maybe let's look like at
the mammal github repository right here
this comes with a lot of example code so
nice loop here and this is actually a
great place to store it if you want to
figure out what's out there so you can
see there's some sharp examples you can
start etcetera many of them are in
Python yes for simple of us - exactly we
we shipped with the tutorial so that is
a great starting point to just get a few
for what kind of functionality is
supported and then we can look at maybe
the first tutorial which just
demonstrates how to setup a simple agent
and kind of setup this interactive loop
so there's a little bit of boilerplate
code and just sending the mission XML
data just going to the to the to the
minecraft client we're wait until that
it's all started up and then once the
role the mission has begun we can simply
access the state of the world by
interacting with what's called the agent
host so it's a matter of getting the
road state interpreting the road state
in whatever way we want and then
starting to send some commands to the
environment so this one is not not the
source
ask so I would say if people want to
know more and try it out
check out the tutorial and get started
on coding up the first agent I mean this
is this is really impressive because I
mean like I say I mean AI because AI is
such a huge topic and people when they
think AI they think machine learning but
I mean you can use Dijkstra's algorithm
to do stuff with AI there's tons of
applications for this what's the future
for project mammal what are you most
excited about that people may or may not
do what I think first of all you just
mention our first challenge that's
origin also just put it out there but
figure out what people can come up with
and I think the future where one of them
is already learning from what focusing
out there and we already think in a
matrix an orientation to every community
like if you have some ideas about what
to be another property a I challenge
please just go to be call the forum
angle bring your ideas because we're
here to learn and then share you know
with with the broader community that's
the platform we will continue to work on
discussed so many queens involve of
import star class to be awesome
yeah well this has been super fun I am
going to go home and try this today can
I just use this with any version of
Minecraft right do I have to have one
that can be modded how do i download
this ah so actually everything is
included in the installers if you just
go to the github repository follow the
installation instruction you should be
up and running in about half an hour
awesome Thank You Katya and Evelyn for a
peek into a really creative way to try
out AI research now I want to go home
and play Minecraft
you got me inspired seriously I'm really
excited my kids are gonna love this
I'm a huge amount of program with this
you
[Music]